[Music playing]
I meet people and I tell them what I do,
and they often act very surprised and they say something
like, "Really, MIT has Music? I didn't know that!"
And I always figure that that means that they've never
actually been onto our campus, because if you walk
around the Infinite Corridor or Building 4, there's just
music spilling out of the classrooms; there's students
playing music everywhere; you hear choirs singing,
a cappella groups, string quartets, orchestras, jazz bands...
The Listening Room is a website where you can go to sample
a great variety of the various types of music making
that's already going on on campus: compositions by
faculty composers, performances by student ensembles, etc.
There are 4,000 undergraduates at MIT, and this term,
of those 4,000 undergraduates, 1,800 are taking a course
in either Music or Theater.
There's sometimes a stereotype about what an MIT student is like,
and in my experience it's completely misleading, because
the MIT students that I know might be amazing
computer programmers or budding engineers, but actually
really want to play the violin, really want to play
the guitar, and can do that very well.
[sound of rhythmic clapping]
My name is Patty Tang, and I'm an ethnomusicologist
here at MIT; I've been teaching here since 2001,
and my specialty is Senegalese music.
[drums playing]
Rambax began as an extracurricular activity
when I first came to teach at MIT in 2001,
and over time it's grown to be a huge ensemble,
with between 35 and 40 students per semester.
They're working with Lamine Touré, who's a master
drummer from Senegal, and the students are not just
learning drumming, but they're also learning about
Senegalese culture, and its a sort of entire cultural experience
that comes along with learning to play an instrument.
The track from Rambax that is available
on The Listening Room is a piece called 'Tuus.'
'Tuus' is a traditional Senegalese rhythm that
goes back for many, many centuries. It's a rhythm
that was traditionally played for kings and nobles, or
anyone important that was entering an arena or a room.
And 'Tuus' is something that is still played to this day,
for the entry of an important person.
[piano music]
The piece of mine that's available in The Listening Room
is 'Diamond Watch.'
About a year and a half ago, I had a chance to write
a piece for an important occasion here at MIT, which was
the retirement of one of our most distinguished professors,
Peter Diamond, in Economics.
One of the things that everyone knows about Peter Diamond
is that he's a gigantic baseball fan.
To me, there's really only one piece of music that's
associated integrally with baseball to everybody, and that's
'Take Me Out To The Ballgame.'
So I made a piece for two pianos, and I think the tune is
pretty clear, even though I never state it, and it becomes
more and more clear as the piece goes along.
I love occasional pieces.
And one of the things I get to do around MIT occasionally
is write occasional pieces.
I wrote a piece to go on the walls of our Music Library;
I wrote a piece for the inauguration of our new President Rafael Reif.
When I'm asked to do, or have the chance to do a piece
that a lot of my colleagues and students and so forth
in the community will hear, it makes me very happy.
We're thrilled that the 2012-2013 academic year is the
50th anniversary of the history of formal jazz study at MIT.
You'll find three types of works represented on the Listening Room site:
one involves standard jazz compositions by our major composers:
Monk, Ellington, Mingus...
[voice says 'Thank you very much' and music begins]
And the other stream involves original compositions by
our current students — these might be arrangements of
standard tunes, or more often they're original compositions themselves.
The other category also involves original compositions,
but from outside composers — some of the finest
composers writing for jazz today.
In Spring of 1963, Herb Pomeroy, legendary trumpeter,
educator, and band leader, was brought to MIT at the request
of the students and the head of the Music Department
at that time, Klaus Liepmann, to come and take over the
existing Jazz Ensemble that was at MIT —
student-led at that time.
And within a short period of time, Herb Pomeroy's leadership,
and magnificent musicianship, turned the program
completely around, and that was in the Spring of 1963, and
in honor of that achievement, in the Spring of 2013,
we are having a major celebration.
We've tried to design our courses in our program
around the MIT model of 'learning by doing,'
so: music making.
Music is design, music is form, music is structure,
music is beauty, music is elegance.
And these are all things that are important to any kind
of design you do, whether it's music or otherwise.
So, by doing music, they're literally thinking outside of
the box; they're leaving what their main focus is, and
they're using a different part of their mind,
a different part of their body, and a different part of their being,
to think about the same issues: what makes something
beautiful, what makes something have coherence,
what makes something have meaning or shape?
Then they go back to coding or industrial design,
and they think about it in a slightly different way.